ich habe gesagt hätten der wirklich
ernst nehmen aber jetzt gibt's rating
kein tor
jetzt gibt es ein bisserl ich kann immer
laufen bewusst ihr junges alter jet-ski
highlight servus und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge zuschauer
überrascht heute mit einem besonderen
format und zwar spiel mir 64er team sg
auf tatooine aber ich bin das nicht
alleine
ihr seht schon den weg wir spielen
gerade in einem zwanziger team zusammen
und betreffend jetzt erstmal hier oben
auf dem dach ausbauen
kommunale howoge st und ich gehe einfach
andere richtung ok andere seite wir
spielen einfach so richtig new big wir
einfach einem 20er team und gucken was
geht ok hier gesucht jetzt hat meist
jungen icao gute sind alle offen sind
auf dem dach
ok dann wir warten auf zehn sekunden und
aber vielleicht auch nicht weil sonst
aber keine zeit mehr die kraft sonst
hatte keine cookies seht ihr mich was
bleibt man der bleibt man hinten stehen
sieht er mich hier vorne
ok dann würde ich mal sagen
let's go und begreifen freitag wir
greifen freitag an
hier hörte dann haut rein ja er hat mich
erhört mich sehr gut okay fragt ob er
muss jetzt leiden wir haben es kurz
editor profitiert freitag der kenntnis
auch mit dem wieder in team sg junge
jetzt geht es bald wie nice dahin kommt
der pink honoriert daher okay
lebt er noch erlebbarer darf nicht
überleben was ist mit dem agb ist dies
nicht bei uns die sich bei uns die die
richtige licht zu bestehen
und die kennt mich die kiwis was machst
du scheiße erwartete mary du kriegt von
mir ein equipment equipment texaner hat
dann hat es auch okay 16 der dsds dauern
fluglehrer sehr schön gek okay dann ja
was dann kommt kommen alle mit wie in
form von wir uns hier draußen auf dem
feld
dahinter nicole fries noch von uns okay
war fischer bietern auch okay wir
treffen uns alle mal hier junge das ist
so geil das richtig nice mary content
noch hinterher so als nachzüglerin kann
mir jemand food droppen hat ihm ein
bisschen routine abgeben kann
nein das ist voll cool
ok dann machen wir einfach so bleibt
jetzt hinter mir folgt mir einfach und
wir suchen uns eingeht nächsten gegner
aus ich sage mir dann angreifen okay so
ok die wussten sie eine kirche hatte ok
sucht ist bei uns hat es bei uns junge
es sieht so aus als komme hier
wir müssen auf jeden fall gleich noch
wisst ihr was ihr machen wir machen hier
erstmal screenshot erstmals wieder
zusammen
ok stelle hinter mir hinter mich auf so
ok und alles klar alle da 32
sehr geil ok perfekt so jetzt kann man
weiter okay dann wie sonst gegner raus
da sind welche da sind welche da sind
viele namen attacke hier listet knife
und so weiter die who wants to live und
die ergänzen und die und flat bei uns zu
diese ganzen unterstrich die jungen ganz
weg heute habe ich eine gute chance per
kopf früh sei von dieser flat sind dann
auch fische peter und der gehört zu uns
ganz schön sehr schön schönegg ist sehr
schnecke ist sehr gut
junge wie nice hier hinten hinten stehen
export fecker das kann man nicht
zulassen wollte ihr euch joh und und
diese unterstrichen wir uns auch gleich
da hinten aber erstmal hier stiegen die
exporte pkw klassen sehr wichtig junge
egal wie alt sind die daums die export
ist auch was mit dem gebäude der steten
auch wir müssen weiter müssen weiter ok
der ist da hinten glaube ich ja mit dem
trend folgen richtig nice junge dieser
aktion ist so geil alter ich meine die
sache ist halt wenn komme teams in jeder
größe erlaubt dann nutzt man das
natürlich auch irgendwann mal wenn man
nachts um viertel vor zwölfte behinderte
idee hat und die hatte ich nichts geht
start down auf seiner eigenen ab auf
tatooine hier
ok ich wusste doch mal was jetzt auf
reinigt brand nicht so national futures
ganz vorne macht ihr wieder einfach
wieder in easy kiel kann das der fall
sein
oder wo ich denn jetzt aufpassen
sehr schön junge hat aber noch ganz gut
es gab da konnte sich noch gut retten
aber jetzt wird's langsam eng ich
behaupte einfach er hat nicht mehr viel
leben
ich brauche einfach oder kürzt jemand ab
smart mit holt sich den killer die sehr
schön gut am anhalter wie viele leben
doch von uns kommen zum spot zu diesem
vor paderborn wo wir grad einen
screenshot gemacht haben betreffen uns
da wir haben die gleichen wie keine
keine
okay mein zeh schmerz ist auf jeden fall
noch ein gegner den gamern und big daddy
ist ein gegner und ansonsten und
unterstrich ihren gegner jetzt auf ein
alter von der fahne geht vorne gesagt
okay sehr schön hier vorhaben wie gegner
ich habe auch nicht dafür da wird schon
geboxt sind da vorne da sind schon
wieder die brüder conti westend im kampf
heute
übrigens was ich noch sagen wollte nehmt
das nimmt es nicht übel so von wegen
niedlich oder so das einfach mal eine
lustige aktion und ich denke mal die
leute die jetzt halt sterben keine
chance haben klar für die ist ärgerlich
aber wer spielt wert ist so man im 20er
team in der runde
da kann man noch seinen enkeln erzählen
ich glaub ich hab das mikrofon weiter
weg machen richtig wird sich alter jo
ich halte mich auch hier bewusst zurück
wollte ich nur sagen damit ich nicht
drauf gehe weil da vorne da ich habe elf
gefunden
wir wären elf gefunden wie drüben fnf
was schreibt er geht trägt unterstrich
okay ich kann einfach sein name nicht
hemmen beträgt jahren kehrt um und
jahren muss jan wo läuft der grat
zwischen dem dach dieser wahrscheinlich
diesen blitzschnell und geschwind sehr
geil alter und wie heißt eigentlich wer
sich in die sonne
ich glaube da hinten ist okay an fsv hat
jemand food hat jemand als dankeschön
dankeschön voll korrekt
ja ich war wollte ist übrigens erst zu
machen heute dass wir die die zuschauer
hier im keller nicht minuten
der typ mit drop aber das war einfach zu
turbulent weil die leute vergessen in
der runde irgendwie wir hatten seit
jahren hatten sind so abgemacht dass die
leute nicht gewütet sind aber das ja
nicht reden sollten aber man redet
trotzdem in der runde wenn man nicht
aufpasst
okay das ganze mal dieser big daddy ich
glaub ich nicht von uns wer noch mein
zeh schmerz dem auffinden
ok dann lasst uns heute das weiterziehen
zehner team hbk
denn wie ok be nice
wo ist er okay die laufend laufen
einfach mal in die richtung ich würde
mal vermuten dass ein gegner davor ist
einfach immer schon jemand dabei diesen
gegnern es zu richtig nice to have aber
okay alles klar
übrigens sollte ich ab ob ich in dieser
folge noch gar nicht gesagt werden davor
schon mal aufnahmen versuch schreibt
einfach mal in die momentan rein ob er
so was cool für sowas noch machen
sollten vielleicht mal tagsüber wenn ein
bisschen mehr leute sind man schlägt
sein vater eigentlich doch der ddr ist
nicht mein daddy us vaterschaftstest
gemacht nicht antrifft ist zu entwickeln
parzellen okay da weiter wahrscheinlich
haben wir einfach kein gegner einfach
gerade wieso der hund der eigenen seinen
eigenen schwanz sagt okay ich glaube wir
haben es soweit alle raus dann laufen
wir hinterher
hier drehen wenn ich es wisst ihr was
wir machen jetzt einfach mal kümmern gab
mal ist ist jemand hier gerade die mode
funktion raus machen kann
da machen wir daraus gemacht
ok dann kannst du kannst du zecke zu
denen die noch leben
orco gsg dass er krank machen nahezu
perfekt ok alles system hinter uns und
jetzt geht's ab da oben sind sie nah ist
liegt er die wirklich harten pictet ich
hab mir gesagt hätten daher wollte ich
nicht ernst nehmen aber jetzt gibt
acting director ich kann immer laufen
boost bild muss ja junges alter dead
space 2 leider ok hab jetzt wasser für
gegner corsa und pinken bikini harmonie
langeweile
herr regel in die sucht ok jetzt einfach
nur noch jetzt einfach echt nur noch
leute von uns und ich würde sagen wir
machen jetzt einfach in wir machen jetzt
ein ffh mache jetzt in sap sowie laufen
jetzt 15 sekunden jeder ein in eine
richtung und dann wenn ich wenn die 15
sekunden abgelaufen sind dann wie beim
revolver duell ist halt ffm
also quasi ffr revolver duell
das was ich meine habt ihr alle top die
jetzt leben sehr schön okay dann würde
ich sagen er jedenfalls zählen die gop
dann ab jetzt geht's los
der rennt also will ich sagen also als
regel greift aber die person an die als
erstes sieht einfach immer und wenn ihr
mit den klassen 8 und markus daun
das wird das wird heftig peter und laufe
nicht weg lasst uns kämpfen combase
mastercard lauft es nicht weg kommt wir
müssen das kenne ich auch voll ein
oder brauchst du gut wenn du brauchst
dann nicht mal okay er braucht keine ich
hab' ich habe auch gut dann lassen was
halten das falten ich sterbe safe im
ersten kampf gewonnen
neben aber ich kann meine strafen sowie
kräften das wäre richtig chef alter wie
viel leben noch zehn leute nach wie vor
noch zehn leute machen es aber so ich
glaub ich hab jetzt natürlich alle nicht
gehört jetzt kämpfen dass ich namen hat
wie kommt das heer wird mein tod sein da
holt mich sein tod sein alter schwede
das war auch richtig knapp aber ich
stand einfach der luft gesehen ich
schwebte einfach hier oben ich hab das
mal kein blog geschrieben einfach oben
nahe und würde sterben heute kein
ardèche bei mir klar das geht nicht wir
gucken uns das nach jahren okay wir
machen immer weiter
wo ist der nächste name ist leben noch
es leben noch sechs leute sechs leute
oder sich nahmen dass ich gleich zwei
nahmen sich zwei namen ok ich muss
darauf gehen drauf wo bewerbe wer will
messen haben möchte mike wilson oben
helfen auch am main läuft gerade vor ari
weg oder ich kann nicht mehr weglaufen
okay du bist du dann drop ich dir kurz
und anschaulich richtig richtig mies und
hlinka parat
da bist du okay hatte ich gebe jetzt
kurz vor 11 uhr live oder nicht so viel
herz hast du hier ist okay aber ich
packe ich will wieder mein trick herein
okay gut aber und dann gehe ich einfach
mal weiter weil du hast doch nicht ab
gestoppt werden wie haben wir noch kommt
dran
ok depping com oder vorne der king kongo
ich glaube der der zu uns gelegen nahm
ich glaube der name reicht aus und
gipfeln
gib mir die böse combo johann knapp
halten
ich glaube der war aber nicht so leicht
so schnell wieder gestorben ist nicht
schade man keine des reisens ist jetzt
dürfen dabei am ist egal
hätte er dies gewusst ich wegen last
aber okay gut wir kommen ins death match
ist noch viele leute da da vorne ist
egal ich brauche es nicht kommen so ok
ja dann
ich hab das vor sich anzugreifen und
trägt ein sms
ich hab es nicht oasis teilten später
teppich gut junge böses aber ich bin mir
nicht sicher wissen schlechteres die
alte b jugend 1
offiziell hat das tier schwert jetzt
hier schon einfach mehr pro yomiuri
da habe ich mich getraut mineiro
da steppt getan und da kommt das dnt
maike peter mackay angebliche bekommt
sehr schön gemacht aber direkt weiter
direkt und regen ok dem ruhig dann die
erschwerte machen sie einfach so dass es
zweifel ob er fit ist
ich bin sehr schön die leute was für
eine runde alter heute jemand grüßen
die celler mäßig einfach einfach nicht
okay leute haben fertig begrüßt ja
perfekt okay denn noch mal danke an alle
die dabei waren zuschauer will schreibt
einmal reinigen die kommentare wie das
gefällt und lassen